bonjour
first as announced by the president the
european commission will propose in
close coordination with member states to
activate the emergency brake to stop air
travel from uh the southern african
region due to the variant of concern b
one one five two nine
at the commission's request the
slovenian presidency convened a meeting
of the ipcr which is the council's group
for integrated
political crisis response
this afternoon to discuss this proposal
in parallel we are in close contact with
euro euro control and esa the european
aviation safety agency which is
preparing a recommendation to airports
and airlines on this matter
we are following very closely
developments with regards to this
variant
our agency ecdc this morning classified
this variant also called new as variant
of interest
further updates may emerge during the
day as the wajo advisory group on varys
evolution is meeting as we speak
the hera expert group on variants will
also meet this afternoon to discuss this
matter
and later today at
6 30 pm
the president has convened her covet
advisory group to discuss this issue and
broader matters linked to the evolution
of the pandemic
then allow me to give you an overview of
the president's agenda for the coming
week first on sunday the president
will visit lithuania and latvia together
with the secretary general of nato jens
zoltenberg to discuss the joint response
to the hybrid attack by belarus
in real news president fonda lyon and
nato secretary general stoltenberg will
be received by the president of
lithuania guitars nocera a press
conference with the three leaders will
take place around noon
in the afternoon the president and
nato secretary general stoltenberg will
meet the prime minister of latvia
arthur's crimeans
karins
the three leaders will give a press
conference after their meeting which
will take place in the afternoon you can
follow both press conferences live on
europe by satellite
in riga they will also visit the nato
strategic communications center of
excellence you can find more information
about the president's visit to the
baltic states in the daily news in the
daily news
now let me uh give you more details
about next week which will be a very
busy one on monday the president will
deliver the opening keynote at the
european hydrogen week 2021 here in
brussels in the afternoon she will
receive
gerhard larcher the president of the
french senate
then on wednesday she will chair
as
the tradition has it the college meeting
as usual on thursday the president will
be in strasbourg to participate in the
european tribute to former president of
france valerie giscardesta the ceremony
is co-hosted by the president cecily and
macron
on thursday afternoon the president will
participate in the eu luck leaders
meeting via video conference and on
friday
the president will receive mr alaskaris
the president of estonia
i would now like to give the floor to
miriam for an announcement
related to
vaccine exports so here i am
bram vaccine experts
so i can
inform you in miram's absence that the
eu will replace the kovin 19 vaccine
export authorization mechanism which
expires on the 31st of december this
year with a new monitoring tool
this means that as of the 1st of january
2022 vaccine producers will no longer
have to request an authorization for the
export of vaccines outside
the eu transparency of experts will
continue to be insured through this new
monitoring mechanism that will provide
the commission with timely
company-specific vaccine export data
the eu is the biggest global provider of
coal with 19 vaccines with over 1.3
billion doses exported
so far since december to more than 150
countries including
around 1 billion under the export
authorization mechanism this decision is
part of broader eu efforts to facilitate
the widest and fastest production
and equitable distribution of kovin-19
vaccines that the world urgently needs
more information in our press release
and in our daily news online
um
yes you have the floor
chandler from uranus it's a question on
vaccination i would like to understand
uh the new newly approved vaccine
for children between 5 and 11 years
is this related to the third vaccine
purchase package of the european
commission and
i would like to also ask if the second
purchase the package of the european
commission for vaccines is it already
closed or not
are the member states still getting
vaccines so basically the question is if
a member states would like to request a
vaccine for children between 5 and 11
years from the second package is it
still possible or they have to include
it in the third package thank you thank
you very much stefan
sandor hello good afternoon
i think we wanted to be very well
prepared for what could still happen
with this pandemic and this is one of
the reasons why already in may of this
year we conclude this third contract
with beyond tech pfizer to reserve up to
1.8 billion doses and this contract was
meant to among other things being able
to provide boosters if there was going
to be scientific evidence calling for
boosters but also to have sufficient
vaccines or doses reserved to
vaccine other categories of the
population such as children so this
contract this third contract is indeed
the contract that would be used in this
context for
to order vaccines for children the
contract has been concluded
quite some time ago as i told you as you
know when it comes to the distribution
of doses this is something which is
discussed between the member states with
the company and i would invite you to
contact the member state authorities if
you would like to know more about the
the numbers um the the delivery dates
that have been agreed uh with a view to
ensure this vaccination of children
thank you
thank you so let's stay with questions
regarding vaccination and in particular
vaccination of children so please do
keep your hands up if you have questions
about this supply of vaccines and
vaccination for children oliver you have
a question about that so we take oliver
online
hi yeah thank you uh
actually a question is
not a vaccination but on the treatment
of the sickness but i guess it's also
within the remedy
of you can you remind us are there plans
to start a similar
uh
uh you know advanced purchasing uh
program for
uh the therapeutical the medications
that are that are that are entering the
market now thankfully uh where are we
with we've worked on that and the
related question to the new ryan from
india i'm just going to ask you here you
can answer it whenever whenever uh you
find hamlet in these 30 minutes
uh several member states have already
stopped uh air travel from uh from the
southern parts of africa what's
you know what's the purpose of now
talking with them about it they are
actually doing it
and do you think when you talk with them
that you should follow the italian role
model which is that everyone who within
the last two weeks was in one of these
concert states
uh should not be allowed to travel
within the eu uh you know to get to get
into the eu except for you know
people going into quarantine and you
know isolation thank you
thank you very much i will invite stefan
to reply to the first one yes thank you
very much so you know that we're
following a two-track approach when it
comes to our fight against this virus on
the one hand we are investing in the
development distribution of vaccines but
on the other hand also investing in the
development and distribution of
therapeutics because we also have to
think of the people that have are
suffering from the virus and are
possibly hospitalized and may need
treatments you know that we have our
developed our therapeutic strategy the
idea of which is to identify 10
successful vaccine i'm sorry 10
successful treatments
and going ahead already with
a couple of veg of such treatments i can
tell you that the joint procurement
mechanism is a mechanism that we've used
in the past as you know for medical
equipment but it's also being used for
these therapeutics and we have already
concluded several joint procurement
agreements with several of these
therapeutic manufacturers such as rona
prevegs
to name a few of the of the important
therapeutics we are working with and we
continue to use the joint procurement
instrument because it allows to
negotiate negotiate on behalf of the
european union good contracts which
allows also to cover the needs that may
exist in the many different member
states thank you thank you very much
stefan as to your second
question
about the new variant the new variant
oliver allow me to say that
we
want to remain very vigilant and we
recommend to the member states and to to
everybody to be very vigilant with
regards to
this new virus which is circulating this
is why we very early in the morning
already um
put out our message that we are
envisaging measures under the
recommendation um
for uh entry of um other countries
nationals on our territory uh that we
want to look at um suspending links
let's say uh with the countries where
this virus has been
has been identified and where this virus
is circulating it's good that the member
states are acting rapidly this is the
aim this is what we want uh them to do
what is the purpose of this meeting and
what is the purpose of our call to
to meet and discuss measures is because
precisely we want to to have fast and
coordinated and consistent measures uh
in place because we want to avoid that
there are loopholes to which the virus
finds its way uh in europe so this is
why
early afternoon at this meeting we will
discuss with all member states about
introducing measures as soon as possible
and with regards to the extent of
measures that we will propose
we really want to be vigilant so we
consider a wide range of measures to be
introduced but bear with us we will
provide you details uh in the afternoon
after we provide them to
to the member states
are there any other questions in
relation to uh to this variant
yes go ahead
thanks secretary
this proposed emergency break could you
say something about which country
specifically
and this this is this meeting this
afternoon with the member states will
the decision be taken taken at this
meeting or later and if at this meeting
will it when would it apply
the decision thanks
thank you uh thank you very much for the
question so with regards to the
geographic scope of the measures that we
envisage and exactly the type of
measures beyond
what we
what we announced meaning
the um
the suspension
of air travel or the stopping of air
travel we will provide you information
in the afternoon we first want to
present those
suggestions to put them on the table of
the member states and then we will be
happy to share them um with you as
regards the process in place in the
council this is really for
for the council to uh to say what
additional steps will need to follow
this meeting but our view is very clear
we need to act very fast we need to be
vigilant and we need to take all
measures that are appropriate at this
stage to
prevent this virus from
entering in europe
yes please go ahead for a follow-up
question
decision or would it have to pass
through code pair or something else
well um i can give the floor to adal
bear for a a more detailed explanation
on procedures that could follow but it
all depends on the nature of the of the
measures that we have on the table uh as
well but at albert perhaps you can join
us we have three lectures
because the matters that we discuss are
complex hi thank you very much um so as
donna said we will be able to provide a
much uh much more detail later later
this afternoon once we've discussed
things with member states but let me
maybe just describe a little bit the
mechanics of how the council
recommendation on external travel works
as regards the emergency brake and maybe
as a point of clarification um there are
two different emergency brakes in our
council in the council recommendations
about travel there is one in the
external
as regards travel into the eu from
outside uh the eu and there's another
emergency break uh when it comes to
travel within the eu's and the two work
rather differently and when it comes to
the one that we're discussing today
which is about to travel into the eu
from from the outside
as donna said it is something that is
designed for to allow member states to
act very quickly which is why um it is
from our perspective a very good thing
that member states can act very rapidly
in order to to take the appropriate
measures in this kind of situation even
before there is a a proper coordination
even though we want this proper
coordination to take place as rapidly as
possible and we have taken an initiative
to this uh to this end
so member states are able to act
already already now the purpose of this
coordination is not necessarily to take
a formal decision but it is a
possibility for member states to
coordinate their actions so that they
can
be properly informed of what everyone is
doing and be able to take into account a
european approach in order to act uh
rapidly but each decision would then be
taken individually by by every member
state so this is something that
depending on what member states uh
decide and how how they react it could
happen as quickly as
after the ipcr it could also happen uh
following that this is indeed more a
question um to the council and um if you
if you need more more indications about
this type of um of specific measures
that are contemplated in the council
recommendation uh there is a pretty
lengthy article in the council
recommendations article 7a that
describes um some of these measures uh
as regards both travel and and and the
personal scope um but as i said uh we
will still need to discuss in more depth
with with the member states and we'll be
able to give you more info afterwards
thank you adelbert are there any
additional questions about this matter
yes please go ahead
sic portugal
my question is for adobe i guess
um yesterday the portuguese government
announced that uh from uh first of
december if i'm not mistaken
um a test will be required to uh all
those that were going to travel to
portugal by sea air
or by land
i would like to understand well first of
all
what are the
implications regarding the
digital certificate because if you need
a test why would you need the
certificate
is this measure proportionate
does it
respect
the regulation and i mean the regulation
of the certificate and concerning your
yesterday's recommendation this is
clearly against the
recommendation because i believe that in
principle those holding the the
certificate or according to commissioner
renders were not supposed to be
asked all the kind of restrictive
measures
and you were mentioning that the
emergency brake
did portugal informed you about this
emergency break thank you
hi
thanks uh thanks a lot this is me with
my christian hat as a as i have the
pleasure of replacing him today um
however i i believe we were actually in
in touch uh this morning with the
with the team uh of with christian's
team on this issue as well and
um we do not at this point have full
information about the the measures uh
that are contemplated or being
implemented by portugal so of course we
will look into them
we are looking into uh what what is
available already and then we'll be able
to provide you with a uh with a better
assessment but for now uh it's still
something that uh that we we're
analyzing
thank you
susanna i have a follow-up question
but
this is quite simple i guess if you are
you supposed to ask tests
to everybody doesn't matter where
they're coming from doesn't matter the
nationality if they are holding a eu
certificate
you well maybe if you of course you're
going to analyze it but
this is quite a specific question
thank you
sure so
in in general terms
as i think is very clear from the from
the reading of the council
recommendation that is relevant it is
not specifically about holding a
certificate as you know there are
different types of certificates that may
indicate different things but it is it
is clear that if somebody is vaccinated
provided that they do not come from a
from a dark from a dark red zone in
principle they um they should not be
asked for a for a test however um as i
said
we we cannot comment on any specific
measure until we take proper uh make a
proper assessment of it and also have
exhaustive information about what it is
and and and the reasoning uh that that
led to it so um i will i will leave it
there for now and we will we can be
happily to in touch with this on this a
little later
thank you very much albert are there any
additional questions on the new variant
on the health aspects of kovid
or for that matter on certificates
i see a few more questions other rita
online can we get rid online
thank you donna um have a
quick follow-up on susanna's question
about the measures that portugal
announced yesterday
uh uh
i
would like to understand regarding the
emergency brake
if uh if otherwise you're talking about
the
evaluating the measures regarding these
border checks for tests or if you're
also talking about today's uh
announcement that of of this
the flags coming from south africa
because the the regional government of
the island of madeira has just
said that
they would not implement that measure so
portugal would have
would be outside
of the of the scope of the measure so my
question is uh considering that
commissioner yesterday said that the eu
countries supported
the use of the certificate and these
measures as well
are we not
experiencing a total lack of
coordination uh coordination between eu
countries already and
is that recommendation useless
thank you
thank you
thank you very much the recommendation
is absolutely not useless uh the
recommendation both in fact both
recommendations put in place a framework
for coordination and this coordination
is something that that needs to take
place of course very uh very urgently
and we have we have taken initiatives to
this end uh however it is precisely
thanks to this recommendation that we
have a a process in place and and a
number of structures where we can
take when we can have these discussions
and as donna said it will be really our
priority to make sure that we have a
proper coordinated approach to avoid any
gaps and therefore health risks to to
our citizens but this is a process that
will now be taking place uh in the
coming hours and therefore
i would reserve any further comments
until that has happened
thank you very much at that bearer the
next one is mosey mosey go ahead
we had mosaic briefly and we lost him
no okay here
hello hi again yes a very quick full up
question to the previous question
about this announcement by portugal
yesterday
as i understand i mean
the proposal which was announced
yesterday by the commission
it will only end to enforce in the
beginning of january of the business
being adopted by the council at the end
of december
does that not mean that there is no
problem for member states let's say
during december
to
decide on additional measures such like
this one by portugal yesterday that is
testing
of all travelers coming to the country
even if they have a certificate thank
you
thank you uh thank you mozart allow me
to take this opportunity to jog your
your memory uh about all of the
commission's work uh and in fact the
work of the member states in the council
on coordination of travel measures the
proposal that of the proposals that we
made yesterday are not for a completely
new measure uh they are to update
existing recommendations uh that that
have been adopted by the council and
that have now been in place for um for
the better part of the of the pandemic
so there is an existing structure in
place there are existing recommendations
that that council has approved and
therefore we are not acting in a vacuum
uh when the council approves the
commission's proposals for the
recommendations it will only update an
existing framework so
um
we are we are definitely operating in uh
in in an existing framework and have
some rules to fall back on
thank you very much albert are there any
additional questions about the kovitz
situation
in room or in the room or online that is
not the case so thank you very much to
both of you and we are now opening the
floor to other type of questions yes go
ahead
is it for stefan
adler okay thank you so stefan you are
free
yes let's get the mic working
ah there we go that one works thank you
um it's migration so i think it's for
you albert
um firstly there's this uh summit on
sunday in calais with the interior
ministers on channel crossings um sorry
if i missed this in the announcements
but who's representing the commission at
that
uh secondly you'll have seen by now i'm
sure that the uk has been disinvited
i wonder what you thought of that and
what you hope to achieve without the uk
there seeing as obviously it's such a
big player in this situation
um and finally um commissioner johansson
said yesterday in her answer that
there's more money available to france
from from the eu to help tackle this
problem have the french asked for any
more money from the commission yet
thanks
thank you very much
this this meeting in
in calais which i'm not sure if we can
call it a summit it's a ministerial
level working meeting
it was
among the topics discussed between
commissioner johansson and minister
dharmana yesterday
afternoon and the commissioner
commissioner johansson accepted the
minister's invitation to this working
meeting in in calais
she uh she also discussed with the
minister uh as a follow-up action uh an
invitation by the commission to the
executive directors of frontex and
europol to this meeting who will also
will also join um
and
i believe the the french authorities
have communicated about the subject of
these meetings of this meeting and uh
all the different aspects of the
question that that will be covered when
it comes to uh who is invited to this
meeting organized by the french
authorities uh it is not so much for us
to say we will be a um a very active
participant in that meeting but um we we
do not define its uh its scope now um
when it comes to availability of support
uh for for france it involves of course
financial support but not uh not only
there are agencies notably front tags
that
that can be
that can be called upon in order to
assist
now
whether we have a specific formal
request or not
i have to say i cannot confirm
immediately but what i can definitely
say is that we are in in a very very
close touch with the french authorities
about all these different possibilities
of support and this was also
one of the
topics touched upon in the call
yesterday between the commissioner and
the minister
and
the uh
the the eu is definitely ready to uh
deploy any support uh very very rapidly
thank you very much i will take two more
questions and then we need to close this
midday briefing there are many other
colleagues who wish um so i would give
the floor to you is it about the same
measure doesn't involve albert
a little bit follow-up but about poland
dominica from polish television i would
like to ask because it was information
yesterday that the commission could
transfer around 200 millions of euro to
protect to protecting of border between
poland lithuania and
latvia and belarusia so i would like you
to confirm this information and if yes
are there any condition for example the
presence of a front-ex officer in this
region or other conditions thank you
thank you very much
in fact this is not an information only
from yesterday but it is something that
the
the president herself announced uh after
the last college meeting and that that
was also
explained in a little bit more depth in
the communication that the college
adopted about
about the situation in belarus so what
what this is is an allocation of uh 200
million euro under the border management
and visa instrument for the years 2021
and 2022
to
border management in poland latvia and
lithuania so this is a this is new money
that that will be available to these
member states in addition to an
allocation of 360 million under this
this instrument for the whole
multi-annual financial framework for
these these three member states so it's
a it's a significant and and rapid
increase now when it comes to how
exactly this money will be spent this is
something that we will discuss uh and we
have already started discussing with
with those member states of course when
it comes to the conditions these are
defined in the legal instruments that
that establish the fund and of course
all of this will need to be fully
compliant with
with these conditions and other aspects
of european law but this is
just a just a matter of course
so we we are
we are of course hoping to be able to
disburse these funds uh very very
rapidly given the urgent needs and we
will continue our discussions with the
member states to that end thank you very
much i will take one last question and
for all other colleagues who wish to ask
questions to us today please reach out
bilaterally we will be available to
provide you
answers on the record and now i will
give the vlog to matthew
the
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you